Earlier today,
Apple fans were blindsided
by a terrible announcement.
The new iPhone 7 won't have
traditional headphone jacks!
Goddamn it!
What the (bleep)!
(Bleep) on a stick.
-What the (bleep)!
-Yeah! -Yeah!
-(cheers and applause)
-(bleep)
-That's one of the old ones.
-Okay. -RAJSKUB: Is it okay?
Oh, my God, is it okay?
It's fine. It's fine.
It's totally fine.
-It's okay.
-It's all right.
Look, you got the insurance.
You're good.
-Chris, what are you doing?
-This confirmed everyone's
worst fears
that the iPhone would eliminate
that tight sweet headphone hole
and replace it
with new wireless air pods
that you definitely won't lose
in the cushions of your couch.
They are, to be fair,
including a dongle
that can adapt
to the old headphones,
but who wants
to ruin their slim new phone
with some big fat dongle
that flaps around in the wind
like an asshole? Not me.
I already got one of those.
This new development comes in...
-(laughter)
Thank you.
This new development comes
in spite of a petition
that 300,000 irate
iPhone users signed
to stop Apple
from killing the headphone jack.
Here's a thought about this.
Um, you-you-you...
you could just not buy it.
-Uh... you don't have to.
-(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-Not an option, Chris.
You're right. On the other hand,
you totally have to buy it.
Yeah. I will.
Uh, comedians,
what's another petition
fans might sign against Apple?
James.
I'm not a Trump fan,
but I do believe that we need
to make cell phones great again.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
-(cheers and applause)
-HARDWICK: All right.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
-HARDWICK: Yeah.
-There should be a petition
to ban anybody with a cracked
screen from holding a baby.
(laughter)
You had one job!
You had
one job!
I have to tell you,
my son almost drowned,
but I stuck him in rice after.
-(Goldberg clucks tongue)
-(laughter)
RAJSKUB:
Um...
No problem.